das heißt mit diesem command ich muss
quasi nur diesen einen kurzen command
eingeben und ich kann diesen blog
einfach vor mich hin und her pushen was
einfach richtig heiß ist
simba alles was das licht berührt wird
später einmal dir gehören würden mit dem
schild dürfen nur dünn
thomas könig der löwen so cool lukas of
happiness war herzlich willkommen liebe
freunde zu einer weiteren folge der
minecraft es heute am freitag ich bin
ganz
wir geben erst mal einen / gzg command &
co auf mein gott format unterstrich
block um einen befehls blog zu erhalten
und dann holman noch schnell einen hebel
liegen können jetzt ganz easy hierhin
setzt den hebel daneben und wir fügen
den ersten command ein wären mir gezeigt
wurde von keyton 200 2200 hallo haase
und zwar ist es eine popcornmaschine
wenn ich jetzt einfach mal drauf klickt
ihr seht ihr schon der block dahinten
portet sich hoch bisher oben den
redstone blog erreicht hat und dann
sehen wir schon baut sie jetzt ja eine
maschine auf wir können jetzt hier sehen
right click to destroy swiss maschinen
damit würden
damit würden wir die maschine zu spaß
macht was will dieser fucking hase reh
niemand mag dich keiner will dich hier
haben was ist los mit diesem spaß das
ist so gewollt bleibt halt da also wir
können die maschinen entweder zerstören
oder wir klicken darauf und klicken auf
get free concert rückwärts einfach mal
da haben wir auch schon das korps das
ist nämlich die erste möglichkeit um
dieses maiskorn zu bekommen mal zeugs
plan und zwar gibt es noch eine zweite
möglichkeit allerdings bräuchten wir
dafür holt also so wie ja genauso im
gras sie bräuchten wir uns rasch ins
inventar wir haben 64 um 13
und wenn wir jetzt hier ein paar mal
drauf rum klicken auf diesem grat was
hier also ab und zu wächst kann es sein
dass wir da rauskommen bekommen zwar
sehr welten jetzt habe ich alle geraden
zieht bekommen aber da seht ihr schon
liegen hierzu ein paar koren dinge rum
und wir haben jetzt die rund 60 und 17
das heißt aus irgendwie zerstörten
teilen habe ich jetzt irgendwie nochmal
vier neue körner korns aus bekommen oder
so und jetzt habe ich quasi diese kurse
und die kann ich jetzt noch an pflanzen
dafür gehe ich mal eben wieder zurück in
den games wurde mir schnell einen
wassereimer
noch schnell eine richtig geile hoch und
zwar werde ich jetzt hier einfach so auf
jeden fall geil dass ich einfach direkt
auf wasser war ich mache jetzt hier ein
kleines fältchen und zwar kann ich jetzt
diese korn cups darauf schmeißt und dann
wächst da was allerdings nicht auf
diesen teilen sondern nur auf den
wirklichen sachen die schon richtig
nassen das heißt hier hier hier hier
vorne hier vorne
und jetzt muss ich halt noch ein
bisschen warten jetzt könnte ich hier
und dort noch einen hier dort noch einen
hinschmeißen dann könnte ich hier noch
einen schmeißen und hier und jetzt hätte
ich vor beispielsweise hier so diese
korns an geplant wenn ich jetzt warten
würde so ein bisschen das ganze
funktioniert mich nicht mit bauen mir
wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen warten würde
würden die halt irgendwann ein bisschen
höher wachsen dann wer hier oben drüber
quasi so ein korn das heißt so wie wenn
ich jetzt von koran darüber setzen würde
so wäre das jetzt in etwa so wird das
dann nachher aussehen einfach nur quasi
sowie weizen man kriegt zwar weit sei
man kriegt zwar körner auch aus diesem
kleinen teilen allerdings auch wenn man
sie an pflanzen bekommt man dann halt
auch weizen raus da ich allerdings
keinen bock habe so lange zu warten um
euch das zu zeigen lass ich das einfach
mal stehen und bleibe gleich bei dem
zweiten command einfach in der gleichen
welt drin um euch zu zeigen dass es
nachher noch gewachsen ist also das ist
eine möglichkeit um diese corn pops zu
vermehren sage ich mal
da wir allerdings nicht warten wollen
hole ich mir jetzt direkt mal den
kulturen und einmal glas und zwar wenn
ich einen chor drin habe und dort ein
glas reinschmeißen dann seht ihr schon
verschwindet das glas wenn ich
allerdings jetzt quad cup reinschmeißen
wird es ausgespuckt und und und und wir
sehen schon ich habe herausbekommen ein
popcorn hier vor das auch noch eine
kornkammer rausgekommen aber wenn ich
jetzt hier ein korn vereinsmeister seht
ihr schon bekomme ich eine tüte popcorn
raus sich entweder hinstellen kann oder
ich packe sie in den letzten slot immer
im inventar gehe es beispielsweise mal
in den games 0
und wenn ich jetzt nach oben schaue dann
esse ich dieses popcorn und ihr seht
schon es ist im inventar verschwunden
das ist quasi schon diese ganze
modifikation wenn ich das corn cob oder
wie das heißt hier zerstören möchte kann
ich einfach drauf schlagen dann
verschwindet das und wenn ich dann corn
cob habe kann ich das einfach hier in
einen kolben reinschmeißen und dann
bekomme ich dort raus ein popcorn was
ich einfach in den letzten slot legen
muss nach oben schauen muss und dann
habe ich dieses popcorn quasi in mich
rein gestellt das ist auch schon command
nummer eins wir warten dann auch eben
mit diesem korb damit ich bin direkt in
diesen chor eingesprungen aber egal wir
warten auf jeden fall noch kurz bis das
da hinten gewachsen ist
allerdings in der zwischenzeit zeige ich
euch schonmal command nummer zwei roman
nummer zwei wurde zugesendet von bipolar
bei uns war dazu nicht mal ein video
gemacht sondern hat in command nur auf
pace bin halt und zwar füge ich den
command einfach eindrücke hier schön den
schalter während sich das ganze aufbaut
erzähle ich euch schon mal ganz kurz
wasser command macht und zwar macht der
command possible blogs das heißt wenn
ihr diesen command aktiviert könnt ihr
blöcke hin und her schieben die ist
jetzt gerade diese maschine gesprochen
von drooff diktierte destroy und porsche
blogs um minecraft und ihr denkt euch
erstmal was passiert denn wenn ich hier
sogar gegen den block gegen laufe
passiert gar nichts kann ja auch nichts
passieren weil es nicht dieser bestimmte
blog ist den man pushen kann und zwar
gibt es nur einen bestimmten blog.de man
pushen kann und das ist ein polierter
ende seid blog ich weiß nicht mal ob es
normal mit ende seid geht ich nehme
normal mit ende seid so gar nicht
sondern nur wenn ich einen polierten
ende seid hin setzte dann kann ich dir
nach vorne peitschen das ruckelt jetzt
ein bisschen eventuell sollte ich dafür
neben den shader und das cashback
auspacken eigentlich müsste mein pc das
alles locker schaffen allerdings läuft
es in solchen commands welten immer noch
ohne diese ganzen extras ein bisschen
besser also stelle ich jetzt vor ihr
wollt euch ein häuschen und das ist
irgendwie hier so eine steinwand und
wordpress ich und dann geht die hier so
weiter und hier drum rum und whatever
und keine ahnung und ihr denkt euch
erstmal oder ihr baut rein theoretisch
alles aus einem seit und 1 aufpolierten
ende seid oder so und er denkt sich so
ok der hat dazu ab und zu ein paar ende
seid sollen drin sage ich mal so in etwa
denkste ihr könnt nämlich dann einfach
hier quasi ich vollidiot man kann nicht
zwei übereinander pushen ich spaß stellt
euch das so vor japan haus und hier sind
so kleine fenster ist allerdings mit
drin sondern man kann so real life nach
draußen schauen und jetzt könnt ihr
einfach gegen den ende seid block gegen
laufen und denkt euch so ok krass ich
kann ihn einfach nur die abruf das heißt
wenn ich da jetzt rein theoretisch man
mit anschauen gegen lauf oder so seht
ihr schon warm war
ich kann ihn blockieren alle richtungen
pushen ich kann ihn auch hier
unterstützen oder whatever
das heißt mit diesem command ich muss
quasi nur diesen einen kurzen command
eingeben und ich kann diesen blog
einfach vor mich hin und her pushen was
einfach richtig heiß ist damit können
sich bestimmte kreative leute locker
irgendwas geiles einfallen lassen es
ruckelt bei mir allerdings noch ein
bisschen gerade winter liegt an der
auflage eine aufnahme oder antwort aber
ich will jetzt einfach mal so ein abhang
herunter schubsen da seht ihr so wie er
ist
fucking dies bornfelder auf eine fucking
flower geflogen ist das ist auf jeden
fall command nummer zwei also wir haben
pushe blogs zwar nur diesen polierten
ende seid blog den ich hier hin und her
pushen kann allerdings nicht meine
wenigstens funktionierte richtig geil
dafür dass mit einem kommandos und ihr
übrigens von command nummer eins hier
ist jetzt das korn gewachsen und zwar
können jetzt hier einfach richtig drauf
machen dann kommen als das kölner
unternehmen das wächst weiter und wenn
ich das ganze nicht mehr haben will kann
ich das ganze einfach zerstören das geht
nur von bestimmten seiten und ich mach
rechts sich drauf und kriege quasi
dieses koren davon runter ja freunde
dass er die colts folge für heute ich
hab nur 21 heute am start oder
eigentlich wollte ich erst mal einen
machen dann habe ich noch im zweiten
rein genommen weil ich einfach ein paar
produzieren wir noch ein rauszusuchen
gestern nach wäre mir wieder 30 minuten
schlaf weniger gewesen worden sein was
ist denn das hier wieder für ein deutsch
ist auch egal wenn es euch gefallen da
würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen schreibt mir in die kommentare
weitere kommen zu ihr seid coole boys
und girls und wir wir sehen uns dann
wann anders